unfortunately I didn't choose the name
electronic cigarette but it's got the
word cigarette in it and it's very hard
to unring that Bell and sometimes I say
you know our products as much a
cigarette is a car and electric horse hi
I'm Tracy Oppenheimer Friesen TV and
today we're in Scottsdale Arizona at the
end joy headquarters and enjoys one of
the leading manufacturers of electronic
cigarettes and we're joined with CEO
Craig white card thank you so much for
having us here thank you
to start off can you just talk about the
size and scope of the industry and how
you've seen it expand since you've got
involved a few years ago the electronic
cigarette industry is growing at a quite
a dramatic pace it's more than doubled
each of the last four or five years and
we're on pace right now according to
some tobacco analysts to hit well over a
billion dollars in retail sales in the
United States only in 2013 the global
estimates for the category are about
three billion dollars and why that's
significant is the global nicotine
replacement therapy market or NRT market
is about 2.7 billion so electronic
cigarettes in very short period of time
has already passed a pharmaceutical
industry and they had a 30-year head
start and can you talk about if there's
been a transformation in public
perception of electronic cigarettes as
the popularity of the product grows
you're seeing a shift not just a min
among members of the public so you know
in New York City two years ago if you
use an electronic cigarette in a
restaurant someone would code would come
over and say you know sir ma'am you
can't smoke here now you've seen three
or four people in that same restaurant
and no one's saying that because they
know it can't be a cigarette and you're
seeing also a shift in the perceptions
of the public health community so
whereas a few years ago you had a
knee-jerk reaction of if it looks like a
duck and quacks like a duck it must be a
duck and of course that's not reason
that's not science that's not data
driven that's just a reflex now you're
actually seeing more careful study and
analysis by members of the public health
community because there been a change in
the consumer market at all is it still
mostly people who are trying to quit
smoking almost every single person that
we have ever seen use the product is a
smoker smokers are looking to use the
product for different reasons some of
them are doing it for the convenience of
using a product
where they can't smoke so that that's at
the convenience is one odor is another
big one
so for smokers odor is often as big a
deal as anything else
because what a cigarette may be doing to
a person's individual health is you know
in some ways just up to them and what
they choose to do whether it's to drink
alcohol or eat sugar smoke that's that's
their decision but odor affects others
it affects the people around you and so
to use a product that doesn't have the
odor so that it doesn't impact others
that's a really big deal for smokers and
then obviously you know smokers
according to the CDC seventy percent of
them want to quit or reduce their
smoking consumption so being able to
have a product that's an alternative to
a product that they want to use less is
very attractive to them and correct me
if I'm wrong but technically right now
you're not allowed to label it as a
smoking cessation device correct so the
only way to say that the product is
effective or cessation or that it's
better for you or therapeutic than
smoking would be to go through an FDA
drug application process clinical trials
and get FDA approval to make those
therapeutic or cessation claims no one
in the electronic cigarette industry has
done that and so as a result we can only
refer to our product as a smoking
alternative the FDA is expected to come
out with some sort of regulation at the
end of October do you think that that
will change do you think you'll have to
submit it for clinical trials or
anything like that the FDA's regulations
that that are that are likely to come
out before the end of this year are
going to be under their authority under
the Center for tobacco products and the
center for tobacco products has
jurisdiction over tobacco products and
products derived from tobacco under this
2009 Family Smoking Prevention and
Tobacco Control Act and it's different
from their drug jurisdiction their
authorities more limited under the
center for tobacco products so what we
expect to see are regulations like
ingredient disclosures Good
Manufacturing Practices age verification
things that will prevent youth access to
the product what about more of the local
legislation the ban saying you can't
vape indoors when the government made
the decision to ban indoor tobacco
smoking that was based on very real
rigorous scientific testing and data
that showed that secondhand smoke was
harmful
well there's no evidence to support that
the exhaled vapor mist is harmful and
and in fact some of the increasing
published peer-reviewed scientific
research is showing that it certainly
doesn't have anything close to the harm
potential of tobacco cigarettes and it's
not clear to me whether whether it has
any any harm whatsoever
and so our policy makers in government
should be making all of their decisions
based on science and data and so not on
conjecture not on well if it looks like
a cigarette it must be cigarette that
that's not data that's not science and
that's not how we should be making
decisions do you think that if your
product didn't look like a cigarette
they wouldn't be as much skepticism part
of it I think is a combination that it
does look like a cigarette creates some
of that confusion part of its also
unfortunately I didn't choose the name
electronic cigarette but it's got the
word cigarette in it and it's very hard
to unring that Bell and sometimes I say
you know our products as much a
cigarette is a car and electric horse
you know but but unfortunately it's it's
got that name I mean we have no tobacco
in our product we have no come we don't
combust we're not burning anything we're
not lighting anything on fire and while
it might look like a cigarette inside is
an integrated circuit ship lithium ion
battery a heating element a fairly
sophisticated chemistry there's there's
a lot going on in a fairly small package
so do you think it's ironic that for a
country that's been trying to eradicate
traditional cigarettes for so long that
they there's been a little bit of
backlash against a product that's
supposed to be helping with that yeah I
mean it's very interested it's a very
interesting situation that the
government and public health has spent
billions of dollars for decades to try
to stem the tide of this public health
epidemic and yet despite all of these
resources that have been spent by the
government they really haven't made a
really serious dent in the last 10 years
in the number of people who smoke in
this country and what I think is amazing
about what a company like njoy is doing
is we're using technology and and that's
what we do in America we use technology
to solve really complicated problems and
so we're using technology to address
this really systemic problem this public
health epidemic in the sense that if you
look again back at the data
the number of people the number of
people smoking has been decreasing as
the popularity of electronic cigarettes
has been increasing great well Craig
thank you so much it's my pleasure thank
you for even TV I'm Tracy Oppenheimer
[Music]